Mother's Day it's the day we honor moms
as opposed to every other day when we
look at our phones and go yeah not now
mother's day it's not just an
opportunity to do something for your mom
it's an opportunity for businesses to be
the thing that you do for them
JC Penney believes mom deserves to get
everything she wants the JCPenney
Mother's Day sales baskin-robbins
Mother's Day cake pick one up today for
Mother's Day personalize your M&MS on my
mms comm welcome to Hooters right this
way
moms Rock bring yours to Hooters on
Mother's Day and Shirley cream perfect
what what better way to honor the woman
who gave you life than taking her to
Hooters mom I just want to thank you for
making me the man I am today a man who
takes his mother to a hooters on
Mother's Day by the way I don't have to
pay for you so order me some wings yeah
even America's national pastime wants to
publicly acknowledge mothers hey Mets
fans come spend Mother's Day at Citi
Field on Sunday May 11 every mom in
attendance is going to receive this Mets
t-shirt on Sunday May 11th make sure
your mom receives this Dodgers Mother's
Day clutch celebrate Mother's Day with
the home team the first 10,000 women get
a raise flower pot it's the perfect gift
for the mom who enjoys the three B's
baseball botany and being disappointed
with her Mother's Day gift in America
there is nothing we wouldn't do for moms
apart from one major thing according to
the United Nations we and Papua New
Guinea are the only countries in the
world that do not provide any paid time
off for new mothers just us and Papua
New Guinea that is unlikely appearing as
Sofia Vergara and Reese Witherspoon
separately great but if it's just the
two of them with no one else it makes
you feel like one of them has taken her
eye off the ball Reese in
in the u.s. here in the US federal law
grants workers just 12 weeks of unpaid
leave and there are some stark limits on
that you have to work for a company with
50 or more employees you have to have
been there for over a year you have to
be a full-time salaried employee so if
you're a freelancer contract or
something like that and it doesn't apply
to you and what that means is that 40%
of workers are not covered by the
federal law so if a worker with no paid
leave goes into labor at work she better
hope it's on her lunch hour and that her
co-workers don't mind if the break room
gets a bit messy and and this is not to
say that women don't take leave they
just have to get very creative about
doing it what we have right now women do
take maternity leave it is oftentimes
unpaid and it is through a patchwork
system where they use up their vacation
time they use up their sick days one
woman I talked to put her maternity
leave essentially on her credit cards no
sure that sounds bad but on the plus
side think of all the points she turned
towards vacation she can't now take
because she has a baby this is
not how it's supposed to work
mothers shouldn't have to stitch
together time to recover from childbirth
the same way that we plan for day
weekends in Atlantic City oh I'll take a
vacation day Thursday call out 6:00
Friday hit the slots Saturday win big
Sunday and I'll never go back baby whoo
and look I look there are women who want
to get back to work as soon as they can
and that's obviously fine but for many
women the current situation forces them
to return well before they want to like
this new mother right now I'm using the
Family Medical Leave for my time it's
not paid and it'll guarantee me my
position back only for 12 weeks I see
myself probably maybe like a month
that's what I don't see myself taking
longer than that I don't know how I
could take longer than that so probably
like a month
that is a woman who deserves real
gratitude in the form of a Tampa Bay
Rays flowerpots just to help her in the
baby and that's if your pregnancy goes
according to plan if a baby's born
prematurely parents can be forced to
make some truly heart-wrenching choices
like Selena Allen whose baby was six
weeks premature and who knew that she
could only afford to take four weeks off
in total we decided the best thing we
could do is to spend the one month with
Connor when he's home with us I gave
birth on Wednesday and on Monday I went
back to work it was like a piece of me
got left in that hospital and now I had
to pretend that I'm okay okay that's
terrible although I will say you have
definitely got everyone's what
I did over the weekend story beat oh oh
really Carol skydiving that's
interesting I dropped a baby from my
innards and I was forced to leave it
right there in the hospital for
financial reasons but go ahead tell me
what you had for brunch the next day you
had waffles you're incredible Carol
that's a great King story look I don't
have to suggest that this is an issue
that only mothers should have to think
about family leave should be thought of
as an option for both parents which will
take some cultural adjustment look at
major league baseball which offers all
of three days off two players who become
fathers but when one of them
the Mets Daniel Murphy actually took it
things happened this week sports radio
skewered him for missing the first two
games of the season for his son's birth
he gets ripped back to your team when
you play baseball that's my take on it
what what you done you can do anyway
you're not breastfeeding the kid said
c-section before the season starts I
need to be I need to be at opening day
oh good luck selling that to your wife
uh listen babe I know I play 162 games
in a season but I can't miss a single
one so let's cut that thing out of your
belly talk and wear my baggy pajamas and
swing a cone of wood to make a ball go
far
so so why do we have this system in the
United States well for a start employers
tend to fear any sort of mandate but
when it comes to family leave any fears
do tend to be overblown look at the way
that lawmakers discussed our current 12
weeks of unpaid leave system back when
it was proposed in 1993 I want to make
sure that all of you who will vote for
this have no illusions this bill will
cost jobs today America's businesses are
already saddled with too many
suffocating regulatory burdens now is
not the time to shove restrictive
federal mandates down the throats of
American businesses and American
families this bill is unfair
anti-business anti-growth invasive
deathly expensive I say this to the
house if we allow new mothers to take
time off work
businesses shall crumble our city shall
burn and hungry wolves shall roam our
streets I'm not anti mom I'm anti wolf
that's all I'm saying no to walks no to
the wall think about the wolves now that
that bill obviously passed and a 2012
survey found few work sites reported
negative effects of complying with the
law so we thought the bill would kill us
but instead we just got used to having
it around like an irregular mole or a
new stepdad I don't know why I was so
afraid of you gene you were fine now now
some people might argue but but that was
unpaid leave paid leave is two-owner us
but is it because back in 2002
California passed a plan providing six
weeks of partially paid leave funded
through a small payroll tax essentially
it was an insurance plan that will cost
employers little to nothing but all the
same fear-mongering took place and in
the end this happened more than 90% of
the companies there reported either
positive or at worst neutral affect
businesses seemed to just make it work
and and the polling data we have when we
when we survey them most of them say
it's just not a big deal yeah it seems
paid maternity is a bit
having hockey on in the background and a
bar it's not hurting anyone and a couple
of people are actually really into it so
so look in California it worked and yet
only two other states have followed
their lead and that may be because any
legislation that specifically seeks to
support women often faces vocal
opposition in fact Minnesota recently
debated a bill which expanded unpaid
maternity leave and provided other
workplace protections for women which
seemed like a slam dunk after all
lawmakers love their mothers in
Minnesota just look at these videos they
made hi mom happy Mother's Day
whether it's one day or all year round
frankly we should be thanking their moms
happy Mother's Day to all mothers in
Minnesota thank you and do I talk about
my mom or the mother of my children I
love them both she always said there's
two sides to every story you need to
know them both before you can be wise
enough to know what to do
okay just pump the brakes a bit because
moms are like feet the more you talk
about them in public the more everyone
assumes you want to have sex with them
so so just just don't still it's it is
it is we don't think too much about that
it is it is interesting the
representative Dan halls mother taught
him that there's two sides to every
story because you might like to know
that he and every other lawmaker you
just saw voting against that bill and
you can't have it both ways you can't go
on and on about how much you love
mothers and then fail to support
legislation that makes life easier for
them in fact until we until we as a
person do something to address this this
should be the only message that were
allowed to send on Mother's Day Mother's
we owe everything to them they gave
birth to us they nurtured us they made
us who we are and this Mother's Day we
have just one thing to say to all the
mothers out there
get the back to work seriously get
back to work now because unless you can
personally afford to take the time off
you want we're gonna need you to get
your exhausted ass back to work and show
us that can-do attitude that moms are
famous for we do anything for our models
up to but not including paying them to
stay home for a while after pushing a
human being out of their body but we do
want to say thank you and what better
way to thank us for thanking you
then maybe turning up on time once in a
while we appreciate you moms that's why
we're happy to allow you to bring that
weird donut cushion to work just so long
as you promise not to tell us what it's
for and if you need to find a place to
pump breast milk well no problem either
use the break room or even better why
not get some fresh air you'll be more
comfortable out there
it'll be like a picnic and mom's you
love picnics the important thing is that
you come back to work when you're ready
or when you're not ready or even when
your placenta is still technically
inside you
oopsie clean-up on aisle 7 look at you
supermom taking care of everyone because
remember not only can you balance work
and family you have to and that's why
this Mother's Day we know you'll be
grateful mom's because you understand
that even though 183 other countries do
more for you we do as much as we feel we
can right now what we're saying is you
deserve the very best mom's you're just
not going to get happy Mother's Day
you